[Music]
let's talk about this uh
ballsy taurus ballsy
yeah we don't know the point yet his
testicles are all
it was a little treat for myself in the
moment
you're in the know okay so there's a
story about this woman
who recently visited this uh
it's called a tiger kingdom zoo in
northern china
uh thailand thailand thailand wow
i bet it tastes good i bet it does it's
because the city is called
chiang mai oh i've been there
i saw i saw a cobra show and the snakes
have two dicks
and then i saw a mongoose fight a cobra
oh
that's why mongoose always wins ricky
ticky tabby
i they're like crazy really i love the
mongoose
yeah well this tourist here she
[Applause]
did some crazy [ __ ] i will show you a
video
oh what the [ __ ]
what you doing wow those things are huge
she
is she nice to it on to a tiger is it a
video or a picture
genitals it's a video but this is a
picture they look soft though
there's multiple softs yeah my puppy's
balls are furry like that too
how cute okay i would grab his bowls too
it looks like walmart
is this guy sleeping though oh
yeah she's just holding animals
testicles all of them
she's just like that's not a tiger yeah
that's a different
oh he's better that guy is beautiful
that's a tiger
yeah a tourist at this thai zoo oh my
god
oh [ __ ] he moved too abrupt from my
comfort zone
yeah interesting
now i see where the pun came from it
wasn't even mine i stole it from the
article
that looked like three balls oh it's
because it's a penis
yeah it's a peanut oh so he's a grower
huh oh yeah
have you ever seen horses grow no
sometimes it's like this right and it
goes
[Music]
whoa it's like hose yeah yeah
and then they don't know that they have
a boner so they're all like proud that
they just finished peeing
and they start prancing around it's like
no way
yeah when it it like expands to pee
and it's like this much off the ground
and it pees and it goes back in
yeah every time it pizza does that yeah
yeah imagine having to
hold your piss in until your dick gets
big and then once it gets big then you
could be like
what if it's already peeing and it just
fills up the dick
oh and then it shoots
[Music]
interesting it looks crazy i don't know
i still have not and i don't think i
ever will seen
the bestiality [ __ ] of like a girl
getting
getting it from a horse man i saw that
when i was young in like underworld and
[ __ ]
i only saw the german shepherd one i
didn't see the uh i didn't see that i
was curious
and like in years ago on jk news i had
talked about this but
now at this point i think i've outgrown
that curiosity and i don't think i'll
ever look it up
yeah there's some things now i'm just
like i don't need to
yeah i don't need to see that i get the
physics behind it i have an imagination
i could figure it out i don't know but
then you're talking about like that
length i'm like
how does she feel that's why people die
right yeah yeah they're having people
who died i died right mr hands a long
ass time ago
a long i saw what you did there
what physically happened to him to i
think his insides were [ __ ]
eroded everything in his body or
something he said
he said break my guts not my heart and
then he got his wish
cause you know how like your your
intestines go like this like does it
just like
go straight but they did say that like
your intestines can be stretched out to
be a tennis court size
yeah but the penis isn't yeah the penis
just punctured through all of it
it's like putting on skewers
tested skewer that's so nasty dude
eat that in the philippines the
intestine skewer yeah
it's called isao yeah chicken chicken
intestine does it taste like
like dukes yeah like poop i mean you
barbecue it
so it tastes you've never had intestines
here yeah just like
in korean like barbecue and stuff i like
beef
i don't know yeah i like beef is just
tastes like uh
like pork belly it's just really covered
in fat the beef intestine
i'm not going to taste like [ __ ] it
doesn't taste like [ __ ] the small
intestines
taste like when they turn it into like
fried rice the korean fried rice
that's bomb it is kind of like pork
belly in there it's just full of fat i
just eat pork belly
a little more grainy oh you know like
like liver
i think um you know this is like tiger
king
where you learn the real world of tiger
tiger light life
and he's just like like the doc there's
a conspiracy that doc was just like
killing the tigers and [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah
his son is on tick tock and always
playing with different
exotic animals and tigers yeah i didn't
know he was related to doc
until i watched tiger because i was
following him for a long time oh really
what happened is is he a pimp too like
you know doc is kind of like the dan
bilzerian
just like he just plays with like we
don't know who's like personal stuff
tigers chimpanzees like an animal guy
yeah and i just thought this guy's
really cool
and then i recognized his last name
though and i'm like oh wait i think this
is his son
wow yeah did you hear about carol baskin
yeah she's gonna be on dancing the stars
investigation about her husband yeah
isn't there
it's sad what we celebrate these days
like who watches that
show like why is it i know joe exotic so
pissed
they always put on like random people
who are just kind of aj from backstreet
boys is on it too
you think him and carol's like let's see
i'm cool with that
come on he's a backstreet boy i think he
could be the demographic
yes and he was my favorite i don't know
i i think she would boost the ratings
yeah but she's a criminal right
or no we don't know i don't know we
don't know for sure
morally ethically she is the documentary
made it seem like she was the evil one
yeah they skewed it
for sure and but she was like laughing
and stuff about it and it just like
carol baskin
it didn't help her this is weird cause
it's like you when you think dancing
with the stars you think former
a-listers
but now now they're just like scraping
the earth for people like maybe they ran
out
like after the first season yeah maybe
they ran out
they have a few maybe per season but
it's definitely not everybody a-listers
but carol baskin that's a big pull
i think yeah netflix number one movie
for a while
that's what was kicking ass before the
whole kobit [ __ ] went down
like everyone was talking about tiger
king yeah no i thought that was after
covet oh no
it was after yeah it was actually right
when it's april oh yeah
yeah can you imagine being like a legit
legit celebrity where it's like
you're in all these a movies and then
you get asked beyond this and you're
like cool and be honest
and you find out your co-stars carol
baskin what is
the minute you get asked you're like who
else is on this no you're like no yeah
my career is [ __ ]
over it's over they think i'm this
caliber now [ __ ]
they probably pay if i got on i'm like
my career started really
yeah yeah i think for some people okay
it is maybe
a start you know what i mean like my
friend jordan fisher
for he won but he was on his way of like
he's on his way right now he's in like a
ton of netflix what was he on before
uh like disney channel stuff oh i mean
probably for young people it is better
you know for them to go on but if you're
older like
maybe an aj from the backstreet boys
you're like ah or like brad pitt yeah i
guess
he's way too high kind of up there yeah
but then if he was asked though
yeah he'd probably be like 90 something
and he probably wouldn't even do it
because i don't ever see brad pitt
really follow your a-lister no matter
what
you can bring the show up and you'll
kind of make it cool
i don't know if it's like if it's like
your career is over like imagine if he's
booked for a sick ass movie right
and he's doing dancing with the stars
that's pretty funny
some people can't be brought down though
yeah so you know like family feud right
you guys know the show yeah steve
harvey's on yeah
the host now yeah so kim kardashian and
kanye were on that
well yeah it was celebrity family like
did you see the
video with like snoop being on there but
it's snoop like i love snoop i'm a big
fan of snoop but snoop will do anything
that's true he'll literally do anything
it's not known
to being like saving a washed up star's
career
it's not like dancing with the stars
yeah that's true feud you know what i
mean like you don't think celebrities
when you think family feud you just
think
you just think like it's just a daytime
tv show that's why they had to specify
celebrity family yeah the novelty behind
it yeah yeah episode
yeah and they play for charity and stuff
dancing with the stars is specifically a
show
of like hey let's get all of these like
former stars oh jesus
and then let's put them together they're
watching watch
yeah and then see them dance and see if
they can dance it's it's not
that'd be hilarious if they're watching
and they clicked on a video about a
tourist holding
tiger testicles and they're watching
this and they're like oh they ended up
talking about me and then the [ __ ]
mad world song starts playing
[Laughter]
i want to see them dance not with a
professional like
have like uh oh it's gonna be a horrible
show hulk hogan dancing with carol
baskin
he's combining random people
that's a [ __ ] show dude that's good
so then they wouldn't even have someone
to instruct them at all well you're this
missional teacher
it would be great if they had to come up
with a dance themselves though with no
outside help
imagine that boring that'd be too
humiliating no one else
they need the professional yeah let's
take them out of their element let's get
hulk hogan carol
baskin taught by our very own kinjas oh
sick oh yeah the genre is like naughty
mix it all up
yeah have you all watched the mask
singer yeah
i know i know it the concept um
but that has i thought it was kind of
going to be like a low a
uh bc list celebrity thing but they have
you know
some really high caliber hi colorado you
know like i'd say lil wayne probably is
one of the biggest ones
he was on there and he got voted off
like his first time so
you know he he was wrong was he sounding
like this did he sound the same he's
singing he was singing i mean they tuned
the voices
yeah they make it a little different
they make it better and and they try to
disguise themselves
wayne brady who i think he's like kind
of in between you know
an a and b probably um to me he's an a i
love that guy who
uh wayne brady but he won well he could
actually sing though
he's a very talented and he's he's been
on broadway yeah what separates the a
and b and all that is it
fame and popularity are irrelevant yeah
because
he he's famous mainly on who's whose
line is it right so being on a
show one knows who he is he says how
well
dave chappelle oh yeah because once dave
chappelle got a hold of him and
and put him in the skit and made him
like a pimp
that was a different side of wayne brady
that i'm like now i [ __ ] love you i
feel you
yeah yeah for sure
[Music]
you